this is a pepper panic saga level
95 video walkthrough
I am going to play the level and complete it
and I'm going to explain why I make the
decisions that I do
its a difficult level
for a lot of reasons, you only have 20 moves,
you have to complete 11 patterns and
they're all pretty difficult there's no
small patternts
if you haven't read the full
pepper panic saga level 95 guide on our
site Pepper Panic Tips
I suggest that you do that first because it will give you
a little bit more background into what
I'm doing and the strategy
and it's also helpful because it has
a list of the patterns you have to make
in order and there are times when you
actually have to
avoid making certain moves so that you
won't
disrupt the pattern that is already there first
better for
paper straight line that serve any color
and that was pretty easy to make the
next one is going to be in
also before I make this one a look
around the boren see if I have a Dell
somewhere that I can
already put together I can see I have to
get poured a lot of places like here
here in this area
but I don't have the actual
with pepper and make it this one as it
nearby
but it's a job or colors in the middle
word here
bring them down so in this situation a
arms going to make a run for cover match
and I guess since I have this morn right
here
and if I make this
blue forever match it also drop in New
paper into this area
I'm gonna make it right here all right
and so that worked out we got our
I'll by the red pepper for onto the
floor now the next match up to this is
a5
ever match and the
mourners treeline it's a and I don't see
that anywhere so
on this gonna make the album look over
the board
now these are hoaxes
you know so the hardest a magistrate and
when you don't have the right
gap which is you need to pare za papers
with the gap in the middle
most the time
since we have such low number moves the
best thing in the news gonna be to clear
out the board
so starting a panic would be great
we just want to try to figure out the
quickest way to do that I have a bunch
grown papers in this rose from your home
Expo the Blue Room and roll the ones
above it with that shot now look things
over again see if I
for got the gap in a pre-dawn continue
growing peppers
to clear out phase I have parted the
gathering here
to green and I have to bring that I
could bring together above it but I
don't have anything
any vertical mergers that I can make in
this road actually
bring another paper down to them
look around a little bit more
ideally what I'd like to do here's
exploitable paper but I don't see
a place where I can do that this might
work
into an hour just one way hope that we
get there are five ever mention the
Cascade or
else there's a setup for on over the
papers for
we didn't get it
workers killed you
now looking for the gap that we need to
make the team that'd be like a pair
peppers
with the the same color like above them
and these are also very difficult to
make so you don't want to waste a lot of
moves turned
like really a
set something difficult up because will
run out
memorial for survival in times like this
when I
I don't have like a great match to set
up money to old generally try to find a
match at the bottom the board
that'll give us more action above them
more things to mention other upturn is
present themselves but
right now i think im gonna go with this
war
most are small chain reaction wall
star are preparing for as you can see a
lot of things and move around
report in that set up things felt so the
party
the matches that are coming up now I
think are the hardest wants to make
because they're all one color
there just for paper matches but the
they have to be all the same color and
and they're just times whenever you
can't get the right color
on the border
will have the first floor
know your me well second to
you can see a community there grown from
from space
are your growth around the space for
ever but always take the match right
away if you get a chance because
we still have far more patterns the
maker or chrome
arts it's a there's a few blue paper
there are kinda spread out on the board
we have to Gabes for arm
for matching them in forever for paper
match but there's
really not a good way to
kill another worn down there missile
actually do it here
case no: in origin
got them we are really
fortunate cuts the dream
so now we want to look around and see if
we have
NL somewhere
I have to double check whenever I look
for these because
for whatever reason sometimes when their
son grown have room for
troublesome I mean the gap is pretty
easy to
to spot because you only have a few
pairs or something like
caddy corner to each other but for
whatever reason
I
attorney really make sure it's not there
before
I before
go ahead and start cleared space I'm so
it's not there anywhere from I'm pretty
confident about that at this point so
work do we want to do we want to start
a chain reaction and cream is going to
be our best color so you know this is a
%uh
off to the side I'm gonna go ahead and
go with this message
for because I love little star
insert chain reaction little ultimately
turn into a paper
got her I'll and you see you
why that how that actually works in a
minute if it's not there
you have way more chances that your
Blake
it's basically like free moos you know
and whenever the
the paper pens going on in whenever the
cascade happens
so you always wanna take that now we
we got a good setup here to make her
final match so that's great
as one point out that this is what the
gap but say that say these words were
here this is with the gap that you'd be
looking for israeli
so in this situation if they weren't
there
what I would do is i would match this
vertical orange match
and that would rock three more papers
them and
you with this basically try to work that
way to where you could drop
born into the space im make your final
match a min ago and pursue level though
because it's a
you know it's not an easy thing to do so
you have to go and do
when you get the chance for them I hope
this helps the tips in our forgot I'm
at that repetitive there are you know if
you follow those you will eventually get
through this level
it gives a lot of people trouble but
mostly I think most to the mistakes that
people make ur just that the
the spend a lot of time moving papers
around and trying to
a you know set things up on leaders
really don't have enough means for that
so
in those cases do what I did there just
are chain reaction
reports look over the border by the way
that you can do that the fastest
and then that'll give you plenty of
opportunities to try to make your
matches and set up new things
hope this helps and I hope you control
soon
thanks